ça lui ont discuté avec mon frère des
limites de cet article paru sur bon pote
intitulé loi de bande de ligny doit-on
répondre aux concours et j'ai senti une
irrépressible envie de rebondir avec une
petite vidéo
en fait je vais essayer d'être rapide et
de considérer ça comme une sorte de post
scriptum au principe de charité
herméneutique et perspectiviste objectif
ne pas dépasser dix minutes
[Musique]
je précise que je ne souhaite pas à
juger d'article je ne vais pas le
reprendre point par point
je vais seulement rebondir sur certaines
idées impliqué par le texte première
précision
la question est posée de manière
générale mais l'article se concentre
rapidement sur l'activité twitter de son
auteur alors je ne veux pas aujourd'hui
me pencher précisément sur la situation
particulière des discussions qui ont
lieu sur ce réseau social
ce sera pour une autre vidéo parce que
ça me paraît être un problème singulier
deuxième précision je ne rebondit pas
sur le fait de reprendre ou contredire
une entreprise ou une personnalité
publique comme c'est mentionné
il me semble effectivement important que
certains corrige les prises de position
fallacieuse de celles et ceux qui
jouissent d'une forme d'autorité ou d'un
pouvoir important de diffusion
je ne rebondit que sur ce qui concerne
l'interaction entre anonyme le premier
problème soulevé est donc de savoir à
quoi renvoie le terme conte ici
visiblement il désigne une personnalité
stupide naïve ou désagréables je
reconnais à l'auteur de préciser qu'on
est tous le con de quelqu'un mais si
vous voulez mon avis ça ne suffit pas et
le mal est fait j'y reviendrai à la fin
de la vidéo
le principe de la loi de brandolini de
son auteur alberto obando ni justement
via un tweet d'écrire est une forme d'
asymétrie entre la production bêtise et
la réfutation de bêtises il s'agit de
dire en gros efforts qu'ils ont dit donc
on se demande est ce que ça vaut le coup
la question est posée en termes de
rentabilité
bon qu'est ce qui m'ennuie avec ce type
d' approche d'abord ça renferme le débat
la discussion où tous types
d'interactions entre individus dans un
cadre extrêmement restreint et réducteur
à savoir ce qu'on pourrait appeler les
chances de conclure
j'en parlais un peu dans ma vidéo sur
l'apprentissage mais je pense qu'il va
falloir creuser ce truc davantage un
autre jour pour faire bref c'est l'idée
qu'une croyance est associé à dépenser
et qu'une pensée c'est comme une vague
or la conclusion ou l'expression de la
croyance genre je crois que c'est
seulement l'écumé de la vague
l'aboutissement de la pensée sinon ne se
penche pas une seconde ce qui produit
cette conclusion sur ceux qui derrière
la phrase qui est énoncé en fait on
limite terriblement le potentiel de
l'interaction on s'intéresse pas du tout
à autrui ni même à la société comme
ensemble de tendances idéologiques et
puis c'est un peu comme si on réduisait
autrui à une machine à débiter des
informations et que l'unique but était
de vérifier si les informations qu'il
exprime son correcte ou non
c'est super binaire est intéressé on se
demande si ce petit jacques est vrai ou
faux ou si c'est dans notre intérêt
d'adopter sa croyance
alors on pourrait se dire d'abord avec
une sensibilité c'est tomber dans ce
travers super naïve qui conçoit la
vérité comme un truc à contextuelle et
transcendant aux communautés humaines
comme si une pensée ou une croyance
pouvait être intéressante bêtes
dangereuses ou bénéfique indépendamment
de la sensibilité des êtres humains
ce rapport quasi mécaniste à la parole
d'autrui donne l'impression que la seule
forme de dialogue possible ces deux
machines qui se décode avec jacques qui
dit je crois qu'alex et pierre qui
répond retremper x c'est tout rien
d'autre au passage ça semble indiquer
une haute confiance dans nos capacités à
interpréter correctement ce qui est dit
on dirait que les discussions ressemble
de plus en plus à ça on ne cherche pas à
comprendre l'autre d'où il vient d'où il
parle on ne fait canaliser la forme
finale de la croyance
on dirait alors qu'il ya comme une sorte
de grande compétition rationaliste
sceptiques où chacun s'entraîne de son
côté pour devenir le plus affûté
possible en termes de biais cognitifs
d'argumentaire rationnelle de billets à
nice mme histoire d'être une espèce de
machine radar croyances incorrect
franchement vous n'avez pas l'impression
que c'est une espèce de concours qui
sera le plus performant dans sa capacité
à identifier les raisonnement fallacieux
et en plus ça tombe rapidement dans un
truc de police de la pensée où tout le
monde se corrige mutuellement sans
jamais prendre cinq minutes pour essayer
de concrètement se mettre à la place de
l'autre donc on passe à la trappe
toutes les interactions alternative
pierre pourrait demander à jacques
pourquoi il pense x où il a entendu
parler de x la première fois pire pour
essayer de comprendre pourquoi jacques
est séduit par x essayer de voir quels
sentiments et idées sont
tâche qui est la croyance en x etc mais
non la question qu'on préfère pose
visiblement n'est pas qu'ils aient la
meilleure réactions possibles face parce
qu'on est entiché comme connerie mais
plutôt est ce que ça vaut le coup
d'essayer de contredire mes conneries
voilà la thématique c'est contredire ou
rien c'est pas très ambitieux aussi donc
un pour jouer les rationalistes ça c'est
ce qu'on appelle un faux dilemme il y a
plein d'autres réponses possibles autres
que la contradiction et 2 vous vous
rendez compte de l' approche
comptabilise du truc est-ce que la
connerie du conte vaut que je dépense
mon temps précieux
bon je trouve pas ça ouf d'autant qu'on
pourrait dire ça me coûtera moins
d'énergie d'essayer de comprendre
quelqu'un qui dit un truc me paraît bête
que de chercher à vouloir lui montrer
que ses bêtes c'est là que je trouve la
loi de brandolini un peu décevante parce
qu'elle est toujours comprise du point
de vue de mon intérêt personnel jamais
du point de vue charitables si on écoute
cette loi avec l'esprit de charité on se
dit qu'on va plutôt se demander comment
faire pour que ça me fatigue le moins
possible comment faire pour devenir le
plus patient le plus empathique le plus
ouvert dans la discussion
comment faire pour mieux comprendre
autrui et étouffé mon réflexe de juger
son discours ou ses croyances
pourquoi c'est pas du point de vue de
ces critères qu'on essaie de progresser
même une phrase qui nous paraît idiote
elle est produite par un point de vue et
être charitable c'est prendre ça un
minimum en compte avec un peu d'amour
pour son prochain juger une personne en
termes de bêtises sur la seule base de
l'expression de sa croyance c'est assez
simpliste en plus d'être totalement
inefficace
il y dit quelque part un article qu'une
réponse part d'un bon sentiment
bon là aussi c'est naïf pas besoin
d'avoir fait une licence de psychologie
pour savoir que lorsqu on corrige
quelqu'un ce n'est pas parce qu'on a le
coeur pur et qu'on défend la vérité
chaque pierre qui contredit un jacques
le fait parce qu'il en a envie
sinon besoin il semblerait donc qu'un
con ce ne soit pas tant quelqu'un qui me
dit une connerie que celui qui tient un
discours qu'on trouve bête et qui nous
agressent il faut qu'il y ait ce
sentiment que c'est nocif qui voudraient
mieux que ces gens ne s'expriment pas si
c'est pour dire ce genre de choses du
coup ils devraient reconnaître que si
l'enjeu est critique et politique
cela demande de se pencher sérieusement
sur ce que l'on peut espérer d'une
interaction verbale entre individus
le problème ne se réduit pas à notre
petite personne et à nos sentiments du
genre moi j'ai discuté avec jacques
aujourd'hui
ressort très frustré oui mais en fait on
s'en fout comme je disais je n'aime pas
du tout l'emploi est présent du mot con
ce mépris est inutile et
contre-productif je trouve que ça ne
mène à rien de continuer à penser en
terme de personne comme on disait chaque
pensée plus ou moins sophistiquées et
produite par un ensemble de forces et
ses forces ne sont pas toutes très
compliqué à identifier on pourrait dire
ceci
le problème n'est pas que jacques pense
que la terre est plate la croyance de
jacques n'est que l'effet d'un problème
plus vaste et plus intéressant à savoir
que le monde est tellement injuste que
les gens comme jacques ont perdu toute
confiance dans les instances dirigeantes
et qu'ils ont besoin de s'accrocher à
travers des conspirations à l'idée d'un
ordre secret pour essayer de comprendre
comment la société peut être aussi mal
foutu le problème c'est pas que jacques
croient que la terre est plate
le problème c'est si news contredire un
plat tistes c'est quand même le degré
zéro de l'ambition autant sur le plan
intellectuel que sur celui des relations
humaines le biais de mon pote se termine
avec une mention à alexandria au kazoo
cortez et son discours qui a fait le
tour du monde
en réponse à l'agression verbale de tels
niveaux laissant par là entendre que
parfois ça a du bon de répondre aux cons
mais alexandria occasion cortese n'a pas
dé construire une voyante bête elle
s'est fait insulter personnellement par
un élu et a fait un travail politique
qui consiste à exposer au sein d'un
cadre institutionnel les significations
sociales et politiques de cette insulte
c'est tout à fait différent
je finirai sur le problème de l'excès de
confiance dont j'ai déjà parlé ici et là
j'ai répété et je continuerai de répéter
que ce danger concerne particulièrement
les gens qui ont une ambition
intellectuelle
quelqu'un comme les de sign for all est
le premier à mettre en avant ce danger
dans ces vidéos sur les probabilités
pourtant il est complètement coupables
d'excès de confiance
quand il s'aventure sur la question
politique un sujet qui ne maîtrise pas
du tout du tout s'il dit ces conneries
là c'est précisément parce que par
ailleurs il a des compétences
intellectuelles
c'est tout bête savoir résonner dans tel
ou tel domaine nous donne le sentiment
d'être intelligent alors on s'autorise à
aborder d'autres domaines qui demandent
en fait d'autres compétences maîtrise et
le raisonnement logique ne suffit pas à
pouvoir aborder n'importe quelle
problématique politique sociale ou
philosophique et puis en convoi
généralement l'excès de confiance comme
une disposition problématique parce que
cela conduirait les gens a affirmé avec
aplomb des choses possiblement fausse
mais cela masque une dimension à mes
yeux importante
l'excès de confiance n'est pas seulement
un problème quand on se trompe c'est
aussi un problème parce que c'est une
attitude globalement désagréable et
contre productive
on est jamais trop humble l'excès de
confiance c'est relou même quand on a
raison donc si en abordant une
discussion on essayait un peu moins de
se faire comprendre et un peu plus de
comprendre l'autre ça devrait déboucher
sur les interactions un peu plus
fertiles c'est tout pour cette fois
salut
[Musique]